our Kylie Jenner and Sophia Ricci
Hollywood's newest two BFFs it's fun it
sure seems that way
the two have been living it up and
giving us major vacay Envy during a epic
girls trip to Turks and Caicos and
naturally they've been documenting their
Fun in the Sun on Instagram of course
the Internet is a living for it because
in true kardashian-jenner style their
friendship is a bit complicated Sophia
who is Lionel Richie's daughter has been
dating Scott Disick for two years
Scott is Kylie's older sister Kourtney's
ex and the father of Kourtney's three
kiddos Keeping Up with the Kardashians
is legit a thing you guys and it's a
full-time job
anyway Sophia shared this pic on her
insta story holding hands with Kylie
writing my 20 twin Tony she is the cool
one Richie also shared a set of beach
bikini pics showing off her body in a
hot pink string bikini the 20 year old
captioned the sexy shot quote on a
mission to tan then Kylie did what all
good besties do showing her support in
the comments writing what we are all
thinking perfection I'm obsessed with it
Sophia also shared this totally casual
no big deal just lounging on the beach
topless pic to which Kylie responded
quote um hello then in true twinning
fashion at Kylie also stripped down
rockin nothing but her birthday suit and
a big-ass hat for this pic but it wasn't
just Sophia and Kylie on this girl's
getaway Kylie and several of her besties
including babies stormy all jetted off
to the tropical paradise to celebrate
the summer product launches of her Kylie
skin line do something fun the group
arrived in a pink and white private jet
decorated with a Kylie skin logo wearing
matching pink Kylie skin [ __ ] suits if
that is that extra now I don't know what
is et recently sat down the Scott and
Kylie's big sis Khloe and he dished on
how he court and Sophia are mastering
the blended family even jetting off on
vacations together how did you get to
this place with you and Kourtney and
Sophia and the kids I saw you say on
your kids your priority how'd you get to
this good place together yeah I think
you just gotta figure out really what's
important to you at the end of the day
you just want to be happy you want to be
content you want to be comfortable you
want to love another level Scott it's
like who goes on their vacation with
like it's like this exes together thing
is amazing I'm super soft so impressed
by it how do you do it I think the real
part is life is a challenge
and if you work at what you want you can
get it but it takes hard work simple as
that you can easily live less of a life
without working as hard and that's a
beaut it's hard work for all parties I
think for Oh Mort Sophia they're all
really it's I'm really proud of all of
them if you've watched Keeping Up with
the Kardashians religiously like me you
know it has been a journey to get to
this place but they really do seem to
have this blended family thing on lock
of course we'll be here to keep you
up-to-date with all the Scott Sophia
Kourtney news so make sure to subscribe
to all things et until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]